じゃあ今日はあの百二十三ページのパティ
パティサンビカトゥッカというところ
あのパティサンビというのは
まあ日本語で those という言葉を使ってますから
あの この まあこのパティサンビという言葉そのまま直訳している
うん？パティサンビ？色界も終わってないんですか
色界終わった あ ちょっと間違いがありました
百三十ページなんです
あのブーミの方で あの四番目のブーミなんですね
アルーパアヴィチャラブーミという次元のとこ
まだちょっと残っているんです
無色界という次元 で 生命の次元ですから
この まあ欲界 色界 無色界
で あの無色界っていうのは色っていうのは物質ですから
このいわゆる体を持ってない生命なんですね
体持ってないんだけど
心だけ働いている それはものすごい特別な次元なんです
どうしても生命というと
なんとかの形で体があって
心がある 体と心の関係っていうのはなかなか離れないんです
ずっとこの体と心っていうのは密着して一緒に行動すると
心には体の物質から出てくる刺激
反応がないと心は回転しないし
心から刺激しないと物質もあの変化して反応して行かないんですね
ですから 普通の 例えば人間の場合は
人間の体っていうのは心に支えているし
心が体に支えられているんですね
両方なんですね まあわかりやすく例えるならば
すごい体が元気の場合は心も元気なんですね
体が病気になっていろいろ故障したりすると
心もなんか弱気になってしまうんですね
逆に体心がすごい強くて明るい場合は
まあ体も明るくなって強くなってくるんですね
別に年取ったっても いろいろ痛みやらいろんなとこあったって
全然そんなこと気にしないで元気でいられるんですね
で 例えばすごい健康的で長生きする人々を見ると
おなりで体が強いということよりは
ものすごい明るく生きているっていうことは見えますから
ですから 明るい心がすごい健康な体の秘密です
そういうふうに両方に互いに依存して影響し合って生命が生きているんです
それは人間だけじゃなくて
どんな生命にも同じなんです
で そこで瞑想して禅定なんか作っても
梵天という次元に生まれるし
そちらでも体というものはあるんです
その梵天に生まれた場合は
この体には食べ物はあげません
食べ物といわれる物質
外から部品を入れなくても
あの生きていられる体を持ってるんです
そういうわけで そちらに梵天に生まれた生命はの寿命っていうのはものすごい長いんです
その寿命の長さとか 後でアビダンマのテキストで出てきます
で 我々の寿命は短いですし
その短い間でも生きていられるためには
ずっと体にいろんな物質を部品という食べ物をですね
与えて与えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
心だけで体が大きくならないんです
人間の場合は 物質の影響はすごい強力なんです
ですから 次元低くなるともう物質の影響は強い
例えば我々より次元低い動物を見ると
動物は体のために生きてるんです
自分の生き方とかね それ全然考えない
ただ生まれたんだから食べると
で なんで食べてるのか
それは動物はわからない
それで繁殖時期になったら
もう子孫を残すために一生懸命行動する
で 育てる それで終わったら自分が死ぬ
単なるこの形を維持するために生きてるんです
そしたらこの例えば我々飼ってる動物にせやって
我々餌あげることしか頭にないでしょうに
何か餌をあげて それで仲良くしようとする
それしか他のコンタクト方法もないんです
人間だったら別に食べ物あげなくたっても
他の方法でいろいろコンタクトすることはできるんです
人間の場合はそんなに体の影響は動物より強いわけでもないんです
それで次元高くなっちゃうと
梵天になっちゃうと もう体はあるんだけど
その体は心のエネルギーだけでずっと支えられるんですね
そういうわけで早く死ぬということはない
年取るということもない
弱くなるということもない
病気になるということもない
なぜならば 禅定の心だから
ずっと一定している すごい安定している平和な心が続けるんですね
それだから その心が作ってくれる体だから
体も心のために一応動いているんです
心のために 我々は体のために生きてるんですけど
梵天になったら体が心のために生きているようになってる
ですから 体は優先ではないんです
で 食べる必要もないんです
その代わりに梵天で食べるのは
まあ栄養っていうのはどうしても必要ですけどね
やっぱりそれは心のエネルギーなんですね
心でいろいろエネルギー持ってるんだから
そのエネルギーで体は支えられる
で 今日説明しようとするのは
その次元も乗り越えた時なんです
いわゆるさらにこの無色界の瞑想をすれば
色界の禅定終わってから無色界の瞑想をすれば
無色界の禅定が生まれる
それは四種類なんですね
四つしかないんです そこはちゃんと覚えておいてほしいんです
で 瞑想方法も決まってあって
いろんな瞑想法あるわけでもないんです
今まで説明したこの五種類の禅定がありますね
第一禅定  二禅定までから五禅定まで
そこまでの瞑想っていうのは
どんな方法でもいいんです
ただ 仏教で説明している呼吸瞑想やら他の瞑想とか
それだけじゃなくて 他の宗教でおっしゃっている瞑想法あったら
それからでも禅定っていうのは作られるんです
色界の禅定は で 現代人に新しい瞑想法を作りましょうとか
もし考えて作ることも不可能ではないんです
で 遠い昔 仏教の世界では四十種類のサマーディ瞑想法を決めてますけど
その中で この色界の禅定を作れる瞑想は一部あります
禅定できてこない瞑想もありますけど
で まとめて必要な仏教に必要な瞑想としてまとめてますけど
それと全く形が違う瞑想も他の人々はやってるんです
そういうのも瞑想なんです
でも仏教から瞑想というのは
本当は心の汚れが消える道だけなんです
心の汚れが強化するならば
それは瞑想とは言えない
それはアンチやらマインドコントロールやら
そういうふうな方法で心の自由を失うことなんですね
ですから 怒りに基づいていろんな修行をやっている人々いるし
欲に基づいて偉くなりたいというふうな気持ちで修行をやっている人々います
そういうのは瞑想に入らない
だから宗教はどうであろうと
それに関係なく 清らかな心作りたいと欲をなくしたいと
この世俗的な この普通の人間と同じく食べて遊んで生活する
その世界はちょっと世界から離れて
もう何にもあまり依存しない
変えない 精神的な あるいは聖なる心を作ろうと思って修行しちゃうと
それは瞑想ということになるんですね
ですから キリスト教でも瞑想はあり得るんです
世の中のね 欲に罪に汚れない心を作りたいと思って
なんとか工夫して それなりに心統一すれば
それは瞑想になるんです
あるいは自分が心を統一して
何か力をつけてもらって
それでみんなに教えてやろうとかね
見せてやろうとかいうふうに思っちゃうと
そういうのは瞑想にならないんです
そういう人々は全然神秘体験を得られないんです
禅定っていうのは現代語で言えば神秘体験だからね
やっぱりどんな宗教でも
そういう神秘体験というものを得ている人々は
俗世間に対する興味っていうのはすごく少ないんですね
俗世間にほとんど興味ない
インドの現代に現れたこのヒンドゥー世界の有名な宗教家たちも
やっぱり俗世間に対してはほとんどもう無関心というか興味がない
ですから 欲がないといえば欲がないんですね
そういうことで その方々にもまあ正真正銘の禅定体験は得られるんです
現代語で言えば神秘体験というものは得られるんですね
ですから この色界の瞑想は
この仏教のテキストで出てくるんだからといって
それは仏教だけの修行法ということにはならない
どんな方法でも瞑想できると
どんな方法ではなくて
まあ何とかの工夫して統一すればいいんです
心を心統一して この世の中に対するこの自分の興味とかね
そちらすごい面白いというその気持ちをなくなって
もっと高次元的な清らかな状態を目指すという気持ちさえあれば
それで十分なんです で
そのそれは色界の場合なんです
一般的に人間の考え方は考え
ちょっと考察してみると
人間にはこの 心だけの働きっていうことはちょっと想像しにくいんです
みんなこの例えば神様と一緒になるんだと
梵天と一緒になるんだと
天国に行くんだと思っても
そちらきちんと体 体 形ということは
まあ頭の中にあるんです
体はない生き方ですよと言ったら
嫌ですよとすぐ言うんです
ですから どんな宗教でも瞑想はあり得る
で 禅定もあり得る 神秘体験もあり得る
そういう超越した神秘体験を得た人々は
普通の人々よりは もしかすると心のレベルがすごく高くて清らかかもしれません
でも 彼らにはちょっと乗り越えられない次元がありまして
この体と心の関係 その人々は自分の瞑想体験によって
梵天に生まれても そこに確実に体がある世界が考えているんです
このきめ細かい この精神的な
まあイーテルみたいな
幽霊みたいな体も嫌ですよと
物質は心の動きに邪魔ですよということまでは
どうかなと思いますね
でもそれも人間に考え出すことは可能なんです
なぜならば 釈迦の時代で
インドでそういうことを考えた人々がいたんだから
で いわゆる瞑想して 第 4 禅定も 5 第5番目の禅定も同じなんですね
第4禅定を得たんだと
得たところにその人何を体験するかというと
自分の心の成長のプロセスを誰が邪魔していたんですかというと
体なんですね じゃあ我々の瞑想は誰が邪魔しているんですか？ほとんど体なんですね
邪魔しているのは お腹が空いた
眠くなる 足が痛くなる
それで瞑想の気持ちじゃないんですね
テレビを見たくなっちゃう
新聞ちょっと読んでから瞑想しようとなっちゃう
そういうことで後回しになっちゃうという
で やっとやっても早く終わらなくちゃとかね
いつでもこの物質世界から我々の心の成長を徹底的にもう邪魔しているんですね
もう八時になっちゃったんだから早く止めなくちゃとかね
それはそういう全ての考え方は体なんですね
例えば朝五時に瞑想を始めたんだと
うまく瞑想を続けていくんだ
そこで自分がたとえまあ六時までやって
またもうできそうだから
じゃあ七時までやったとする
七時になったら もう八時になっちゃったんだから止めなくちゃと思っちゃうでしょうね
あ 朝ごはん作らなくちゃ
なぜそうなるかというと
これは体のことなんです
あるいは なんかもう九時にやることがありましたから
今ちゃんと部屋の掃除をして
もう準備しなきゃ間に合わないと思ったりする場合でも
体のことを考えている
ですから 人の我々の瞑想にしたっても
誰の瞑想だっても もうこれ瞑想
心の成長 瞑想といったって
心の成長を妨げているのは体
で 第二禅定を生まれるときは
この五蓋は沈んじゃうんだと
心に 書いているんですね
五蓋 五蓋は全部体に関する感情なんです
欲でしょう  一番目は カマーラ・タンハ
二番目は怒りでしょう
三番目はティーナ・ミッドですね
昏睡睡眠でしょう  四番目は情交ですか
心の混乱状態  で 五番目は疑いという
しっかりしない心が で
その五つの体のせいで生まれるものなんです
ですから 第二禅定を作られた人っていうのは
まあ体をいくらか意味がないと抑えておいて
まあどうでもいいということはしないと
そういう気持ちにならないと第二禅定が生まれてこない
そこでなんで第二禅定で止まっちゃいますかね
続けないかというと また体のことを邪魔しているんです
そういう説明はもう随分前
何回なんかも聞きましたから
で 第二禅定の場合はこのヴィパッサナーとヴィチャーラですか
認識という二つを抑えなくちゃいけない
認識なしに統一しなくちゃいけない
認識っていうのは考えることなんですね
で 言葉で考えなくても
ものは見てみたらすぐ一体になるということは
第二禅定なんですね そうすると
まあ一般我々の立場から見れば
もうなんか頭がおかしいと
何も考えない人やと 何かものを見たら
すぐそこでも我を忘れてそこに止まったままだよという風な状態の人なんです
で 普段我々はそんな状態になりたくない
何も頭に考え方が浮かばない状態は一番怖いんです
あ これは危ないな だから
ものすごい頭の中でいろんなことを妄想
概念 考えることを安心だと思っちゃうんです
やっぱりそこで体に邪魔されているということなんです
それも体なんです そこで第三禅定も同じく
[背景音楽]スック 楽ということを抑えなくちゃいけない
楽を体で感じる 別に楽ということは感じなくても
そうして心はできるんだということに進めなくちゃいけない
で 四番目の最後の禅定っていうのは
まあウペッカーですか
なんもそういう体の感覚はもう何もない状態
シャの状態 何も感覚はない
もう体はもうなしと それまでそこまで体に対する執着を抑えて抑えていかないと
第四禅定まではいかない
そのレベルでも その人がやっぱり体に支えられて心が動いている
大体世の中の瞑想っていうのはそこら辺で終わるんです
で 釈迦様の時代にインドではやっぱり今まで邪魔してきたのはこの体ではないかと
よく知恵があって しっかりと具体的にものを見られる仙人たちがいたんです
なんで私に第一番目の禅定というか
まあそういう風に考えなかったかもしれませんだけど
第一番目の神秘体験が難しかったかと
あるいはなぜ得られたかというと
色欲的な欲を捨てたところで得られたんだと
なんでその状態でいてまた進めなかった理由は
やっぱり体に邪魔されていたんだと
で もうちゃんと観察するとわかるんです
そういう人々はやっぱり物質的な
この体ですね は心の成長に邪魔ですよと
心が体という乗り物に乗って動かなくちゃいけない
そうすると体のエネルギーで心のスピードをコントロールされるわけですね
じゃあ体から離れてもらっちゃえばどうですかと
そうするとどこまでも無限に心が稼働できるんじゃないかなというふうなことになっちゃうんですね
そこでこの第一番目の無色界の禅定が出来上がっちゃうんですね
で 瞑想法は あの   一番目はアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナといって
空無辺っていう状態なんですね
そこはこの概念のことで
このアーカーサーナンチャー空無辺
で この空無辺というアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナという概念どうやって出てくるかっていうのは
この物質的な この 心の認識をね
ない状態に集中する 例えばこの
こういう風に まあこの禅定ないんだからね
まあ一般的に理解しようとしますけど
例えばこの宇宙にすべての物質が消えたら何があるんですか
今我々は空を見るといろんな宇宙の物質見えるでしょ
星やら全部物質ですからね
空でも何でも ですから我々宇宙はすごい巨大だというのは
この物質を見て あ こんなに大きいんですか？と考えちゃいますよね
そこで科学者は宇宙の領域あるんです
ちゃんと あ こういう風に物質はここまで広がっているんだと
宇宙の果てっていうのは科学ではあるんです
そこで我々頭でちょっと考えてみましょう
もし物質は全部消えちゃったら
果てっていうのはありますかね
それで無限でしょ それだけのことで
この空無辺という言葉はわかるかどうか分かりません
アナンタ・アンタというパーリ語なんですね
アンタっていうのはリミットがあるということで
リミットなんですね アナンタっていうのはアンリミテッド
リミテッドと書かないと
無限 あるいはバウンという言葉でもいいし
バウン バウンダリー  英語ではまたいろいろありますけど
また我々学問的に使う言葉はファイナイト
こちらに使う言葉はインファイナイト
そのまあ 学問的に仏教を英語で書く場合は
大体使うのはファイナイト
インファイナイトという言葉なんです
一般英語で言えばリミテッド
アンリミテッドというぐらいのことでわかるだろうと思います
パーリ語でアンタ アナンタ
ファイナイトっていうのはリミットがあるという意味で
インファイナイトっていうのはリミットがないっていうことなんですね
あ 日本語で言えば制限無制限ですね
こちらは制限であって
こちらは無制限 制限 無制限という言葉でいいんじゃない
無限というよりはわかるでしょうと思います
宇宙に物質があると 宇宙の大きさは制限しています
物質が全部消えちゃったら
宇宙っていうのは無制限という状態になるんです
そこでその五番目の第四千条を作った人が
今このかなり まあほとんど無制限的に広げるような
この物質的なことを認識できるんですね
そこで物質をない状態を認識して
さらに集中しようとする
そうすると物質がない状態っていうのは無制限という状態
だから宇宙のことで計算すると空無辺という言葉そこでできちゃったんですね
アーカーサンアナンタンという空っていうのは
もう何もない状態 物質のない状態
物質のない状態だったら
正真正銘の無制限という概念ができる
それに集中するということは大変な難しいことなんです
ものすごいものすごい力強い心がないと
この心のエネルギーっていうのはものすごくないとできない
ですから そのもう知見界から無知見界に飛び出すということは
もうかなり難しい もう次元を飛び出すことなんです
で その人には心にも何も認識しない
何も認識しないといっても
この空ということを認識する
あるスペースですか この宇宙の何もない状態
物質のない状態を認識して一体になって
心がものすごい巨大に広げた状態になっちゃうんです
無制限に広げた状態 我々の心は体だけに留まってるんです
それぐらい制限されてるんです
そこで人間にはこのすごい
このパーソナリティある人やらね
ない人いるんですね 例えばすごい人格がある人が来たら
この周りそこら辺の自分の心のエネルギーは広がるでしょ
で まあそれなりの人格の徳の高い人がね
例えばこの場所に来たら
まあその人の力がずっと広げちゃうし
みんな他のことを考えることできなくなっちゃう
その人を見ているか その人言ってることを聞いているかということになっちゃうんです
アメリカ大統領は東京に来るんだと思ったら
東京全体的にその人の色に染めてしまうちゃうんです
で 我々全然ニュースも見なかったと思ったっても
あちこち行くとすぐ感じちゃうんです
いろんなもう 感じが違うんだと
警察の売りが違うんだと
何だろう あ 大丈夫だってなっていうことになっちゃうんです
そういう風にこのプレセンのすごい人が来ると
もう大体人間でもわかるものだから
心の領域ですね 心の縄張り
だから体だけの縄張りを持ってる人はもうほとんどいるとみんな気がつきますけど
いないと忘れちゃうと
で そういうプレセンない人がもう一人一人に何か言いたい場合は
もうテレでね ねえもうあんたちょっと聞いてという風に言わないと
隣の人は気がつかないとかね
で そういうふうなことになっちゃうんです
まあそれはあの自由自在にコントロールできる人もいるし
まあ俗世間ではそれコントロールできませんだけどね
まあ修行の世界では巨大に自分のプレセンを広げようと思ったら広げられるし
ただ自分がいてもいないように感じてほしいと思っちゃえばそれもできるし
もうずっと広げるか中に小さくしておくかと
どっちでもできますけどね
でも俗世間の人々にはそれはできないし
生まれつき自分持っているエネルギーでまあ堂々と頑張っていく
一般の人っていうのはいかに広げようということをは考えているんですけど
一人で認めてほしいと思って
それから 3人  4人  5人
6人  100人には認めてほしいとか
それで国のみんなに認めてほしいとかね
それでいろんな工夫してはいますけどね
だから一番この自分の心を広げてほしければ
一番簡単なのはすっごい明るい心と人の心を理解するということ 2つなんです
そこはほとんどみんなわかってないんですね
自分がすごく明るくなると
明るい心には誰も惹かれちゃうし
そこで相手のことを理解しちゃえば
相手の心のエネルギーを通って自分の心のエネルギーつなげちゃうんです
だから人の心っていうのは
一つの鎖の輪っかに例えれば
自分が隣の人の心をそこに自分がつなげると
そうすると自分の心が輪っか 2つの鎖になっちゃうんです
もう一人の人が来たら
その人も理解して そこで自分の 3番目の輪っかもつなげちゃう
そういう風に この網みたいに自分の心のエネルギーを広げることができるんです
それに必要なのはすごい明るさなんですね
明るさなんてこのつなげることを可能にしちゃうんです
だってプラスチック 鉄棒をつなげないでしょうに
鉄は鉄にもつなげられるんですね
簡単に ですから 心にある粘着剤っていうのはもう明るさなんですね
それがあると だから自分が明るければ相手の明るさが表に出てくる
で つなげられるんです
簡単に 相手を理解することによって
もうつなげてしまった
相手逃げられない 自分のことをよく理解しているその人から逃げられない
で そこは心のエネルギー
心のエネルギー広げる方法なんですね
で たくさん人々に人気ある人々を観察してみてください
その 2つ持ってる 我があると逆なんです
すごい人気ある人もすごい我が強くなってわがままになったらどんどん人気が消えちゃう
みんなに嫌になっちゃう
周りの人々は有名だからお手伝いしているんだけど
まあ本当は嫌なんです
そういう人々は 自分に何かタレント持ってるならば
タレント才能持ってるならば
それある限りは何とか生きていける
才能がちょっと弱くなっちゃうと
もう誰もない 一人ぼっちになってしまうんです
そういうことで この心広げるためには
そういう 2つの方法ということ
政治家の方々にも教えてあげてください
この無知解の 1番目の禅定の場合は
その無制限に心のエネルギーが広げちゃうんです
それは瞑想ですることで
特別にこの今私が説明したのは
人と人の心をつなげて自分の心にすることなんです
だから細胞 もう 1細胞と一緒になって
2つの細胞のボディになるような感じで
大きくなる方法なんです
それは瞑想には関係ないんです
瞑想の場合は この 1個の心が自分が大きくなるんですね
それは修行の世界でしかありえない
まあそういうとにかく瞑想でこう無辺という態度で
この色はない状態 物質のない状態に集中して
大地禅定を作らなくちゃいけない
ですから 瞑想方法一つです
もしキリスト教の方々が無色界の禅定をそこらへんと思うならば
それでマリア様を念じることではダメなんです
いくらアーメン アーメンとかなんとかと言ったって出てこない
なぜならばそちらに物質があるんだから
無色界に住みたければ
物質もない 天国もない
何もない 無制限的な状況に集中しなければならない
ですから そこで神の世界は終わっちゃうんです
神様がいると絶対的に信じて瞑想できるならば
もう第五番目まで すべてもう置いといて瞑想しないと無色界は出てこない
ということで このインド世界では無色界の瞑想の文献がない
今残っているのは仏教だけで
仏教にもあるのはお釈迦様が発見したものではないんです
無色界の瞑想 それはまあ
お釈迦様が教えてもらったものなんです
自分の先生を二人挙げましたから
いたんです その人々は自分で別に別なカテゴリーの別な伝統の人々であって
ブラマン教の伝統の人々
ブラマン人でしたけど
その伝統ではなかったんです
家はブラフマン・ブラマン人で修行ほとんどブラマン人もしましたからね
それはそうでしたけど
ブラマンの教えではなかった
バラモン的な教えはとにかく梵外虚滅という一体になりたいということでした
じゃあ そういう風にこのさらにさらに広げて
この第四種類があるんです
二番目はヴィンヤーナンチャヤタンと書いて色無辺ですね
色無辺というのはすごいわかりやすいことで
物質がなくなったら空無辺ということはわかるんですね
宇宙に物質が消えちゃったら無制限的ですよ
それと自分の心が一体になるでしょうに
そこで あ 自分の心は無制限になった
心が無制限だと第二番目の禅定が生まれるのです
そこで宇宙のことを考えない第二番目の禅定の場合は
自分の心の状態を観察して
また一体感できちゃったら
もう宇宙とは物質とか次元とは何も関係なく
心の無制限さと一緒になって禅定が生まれる
それが第二番目 第三番目っていうのは
自分が心に引っかかっていたんだ
心に引っかかったら 心のスピードにまた制限される
ですから 心にも引っかからないで何もないと
アキンチニャンという
じゃあ空間的なものも認識しないと
心そのものを認識しない
何もない状態を やってみようということで
第三目の無識界が生まれるんです
これはまあ説明するのは簡単ですけど
これものすごいもう難しい状態なんです
それ得た人が次にもう
それも心の働きだからね
あ 心には働きがあるんだからね
認識する それで心が弱った
働かなくちゃいけないんだ
認識しなくちゃいけないんだから
もしこの認識する邪魔なこの働きをやめたらどうですかということで
心にこの何も認識しない状態を訓練する
で 何も認識しない状態を訓練したら
また禅定が生まれちゃうんです
ですから その場合は心があるかないかとは言えない状態になっちゃうんです
あるんだけど 何も認識しない
だから非想非想相なんとかというんですね
認識あるとも言えない
認識がないとも言えない状態になるんだと
それはもう終わりと それ以上瞑想はありません
それ以上あるならば 認識は止まるということなんですね
だから認識は止まると
また人がいるということはちょっと矛盾で成り立たないんですね
そこができるのはヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界だけなんです
いわゆる存在というそのものも捨てると
そこ以上は言葉はないし
人間に考えることも不可能なんです
言葉あるのはこの非想非想相場のところまでなんです
これ以上のもう一つ瞑想のステップはあるんです
そのステップはこのヴィパッサナー瞑想して阿羅漢になった聖者がサマーディ瞑想もして
無識界の瞑想も全部つも終わって
自分のヴィパッサナーの智慧
悟りの智慧を使って全部止まっちゃうんです
心 その人に体も存在しない
その時心も存在しない
だからいるという状態にならないんです
だから何も言う言葉にならない状態になっちゃう
それは無量だというんですね
そういう禅定はありますけど
それはまあ人間にできるものでなくて
阿羅漢になって聖者だけできる瞑想態ですね
そういうことで この禅定の立場から言えば
色界の禅定っていうのはごく一般的に世の中でどこにでも見られる
無色界っていうのは ものすごい稀に自由な人間に生まれる可能性
宗教に引っかかってない自由な人間に生まれる可能性あります
で それ次のステップの瞑想っていうのは
仏教の世界だけでできることなんです
なぜ仏教の世界でジェダストの次元で生まれるんだから
別に仏教でなくてもいいんです
まあ無常観察して悟りを開くならば
まあその世界で生まれる
じゃあこの今日は次元論の最後ですから
この次元として この体
いわゆる物質を乗り越えた人の生まれるところが
生まれるところというか
生まれる状況ですね ところはないんです
ところといえばもう次元
次元だから空間だから
場所はない 場所がないということは
なかなか人間には理解できない
私はここにいますという場合は
そこで場所があるでしょうに
だからこれ私ですよと我々は物質を指さして言うんです
神々も場所を取るんです
宇宙の 梵天も宇宙の場所を取っているんです
それは次元違うんだから
まあダブっちゃいますけどね
で 無色界の人々は場所を取らない
だからもうどこにいるかということ意味がないんです
どこということはない
いるんです どことはありません
我々の言葉で言えば いると言えばどこにいるんですかと
どこにもいないんだけど
いるんですよと言っちゃったら
エリフォスだよとなってしまう
それは無色界の次元なんですね
だからつありますと このつも心のエネルギーのちょっとですね
それで次元は終わります
そこで最後にこの全部
まとめて このスッダーワーサという
あの仏教で特別な梵天の次元決めてますね
それは上空天ですか？上境天ですか？上位天？上戸天
この上戸天には-